cómo le va
a mí me define todo eso que dijieron y
me definen mil cosas más
me definen mis tres amores me definen mi
familia
me define mi pasión me define mi carrera
me definen mis amigos mis pacientes
mis tropiezos
soy una persona que sé que quiero hacer
y que puedo ser que todo lo puedo y como
todo lo puedo me junte con gente que
también puede y que formamos un grupo el
grupo llama previa sin alcohol no es
para romperle a los adolescentes es para
poder enseñarle a los padres y enseñar a
esos chicos que como están tomando la
van a pasar mal como como están tomando
van a tener consecuencias graves
hay dos pilares fundamentales que me
hicieran pertenecer unas la pediatría de
los cinco años que quiero ser pediatra
voy a ayudar me gusta la medicina social
me gusta pertenecer y los a mis
pacientes les dejo la cabeza así y otra
fue mi viejo yo se los describo viejo y
así así así 17 meses
así ya canal bulldog que mataba pero era
así el tipo de alas y la carita la ponía
por las dudas mi viejo como padre fue
soñado mi viejo como hijo la pasó mal
muy mal su padre era alcohólico
nosotros por mi viejo no nos enteramos
nada pero pudimos saber que a veces lo
tuvo que ir a buscar un lugar pudimos
saber que mi abuelo le dio vergüenza
entonces no lo fue no pudo ir al
casamiento
pero mi viejo como viejo todo lo que
tenía de grande lo tenía de genial me
dijo te abrazaba y se te solucionaba el
día cuando hablaba casa te dijo cásate
en diciembre un amigo de mi hermano
adrián venía como más seguido a casa
siempre como que los mediodías tenía
problemas y había problemas y tenía
todos las zapatillas de moda las tablas
de surf las motos las chombas no se
ponía una chomba lacoste ponía dos una
palabra el huesito la otra estaba todo
prolijito díaz lo tenía todo este 24 de
diciembre que cayó sábado adrián le
empezó a pegar piñas al porche de mi
casa
mi papá salió lo abrazó los llevó a sus
piezas a los dos segundos ya estaba
sentado almorzando con nosotros que le
dijo mi papá que tenía cinco palabras no
sé yo lo que vi es que le dio su abrazo
de oso
adrián lo tenía todo pero en ese momento
no tenía ni a su papá ni a su mamá
estaban con problemas de adultos
el abrazo de oso mi viejo curaba sanaba
el cerebro decía
pues te apoyamos ahí y por lo menos si
te sea más fácil
qué pasa en el cerebro adolescente el
ser adolescente está en formación se
forma entre los 22 y 25 años se termina
de formar sobre todo esta partecita a la
vista atrás de la corteza prefrontal que
es la que da el juicio el que déjamelo
pensar esta formación
entonces nosotros a veces queremos
pretender del adolescente algo que no
puede representamos al cerebro
adolescente una casa que le están
haciendo entonces vos vos pasa por acá
es que bien que valoras el vecino tiene
paredes tiene este hecho pero quizá le
falta la ventana y sale falta la puerta
quizá le falta una grifería entonces vos
ves una casa pero las funciones totales
de la casa no están falta entonces no
pidamos al adolescente que haga lo que
todavía no puede sí que hacemos lo
acompañamos
si cuando nació en otro bebé lo teníamos
así en bracito y no nos faltaba más
porque sabíamos que se iba a golpear
contra el piso y cuando era chiquitito y
tenía que aprender a cruzar la calle y
lo agarraba mosela malas y mira para acá
mira para allá y le enseñamos y ahora
como adolescentes porque nos corremos
señores no nos corramos el capaz que
tenemos que mirar para arriba porque el
pib es así pero no lo corra no nos
corramos de esa situación no tiene bola
y adolescente no existe la enfermedad
adolescente tease no nos corramos
ayudemos a nuestros adolescentes a
transitar la independencia eso también
se enseña
de que mueren los chicos de cinco chicos
uno muere por causas de alcohol esta es
prevenible
los chicos cuando salen hoy es viernes
hoy muchos van a salir la mitad de los
que salen van a tomar de forma abusiva
el 30 por ciento de los chicos que hoy
van a salir van a tomar alcohol hasta
perderse mamar se salen dos veces por
semana y el 30% va a tomar mal
entonces ahora
pensar en el nombre de tu hijo
no importa si es chiquito o si ya es
adolescente pensarlo y pensar que va a
salir es hoy porque bueno de este
permiso o mañana entonces vos pensás que
tu hijo puede estar en este 50 que no
todo va a morir o en este 50 que toma
que le pegue porque esta es la
definición o que toma que le rompa
y bueno sabes en cuál de los dos lugares
va a estar porque el chico puede tomar
porque quiere o puede tomar para
pertenecer
entonces tenemos que acompañarlo igual y
si tanto te tocó en el 50 de que le
rompe puede pasar que las cuatro de la
mañana te suelen tu teléfono ve a sus
números desconocidos sones de terapia
intensiva y tu hijo va a estar intubado
y tu hijo va a depender de máquinas para
vivir
o puede pasar que como le rompió se
subió al auto que vos se lo diste y como
es normal tomar alcohol tuvo un
accidente como está pasando en nuestras
avenidas y ese accidente y cátac inició
nada el paralizó al otro o quizás como
está tan normalizado tomar
tu hijo no tomo pero si se subió en el
auto de uno que tomo y también le pudo
pasar algo
y se rompió y se olvidó de ponerse el
hay enfermedad de transmisión sexual hay
sífilis en adolescentes hay embarazos no
deseados hay hb
el alcohol es la puerta de entrada a
otras drogas el consumo de nuestros
adolescentes se llama paul y consumo
poli es más de 1 alcohol con otras
sustancias
es la puerta de entrada
hago enfermedades psiquiátricas y en
generado una alteración bastante
importante a nivel cerebral bueno en
vuestra casa esta casa estaba construida
tenían las paredes las paredes del techo
y como tiene que romper un fin de semana
voy y le sacó unos bichitos otro fin de
semana como no sale el sol o ninguno al
otro de saque 15 me la puse facebook
y así sucesivamente
mucha cantidad de tiempo
dos veces a casa esa casa está enterita
pero tiene problemas al largo tiempo
que tenemos que hacer con otro
adolescente estar acompañarlo es fácil
no
es un tipo que se convirtió en algo raro
un visto cómo se come mi
definición adolescente es sujeto volador
no identificado sujeto es un sujeto que
mágicamente preadolescencia le empieza a
crecer un órgano en la mano que capta
wifi por todos lados
genial el celular y ellos uno solo
volador nunca ha visto un pibe sentarse
tan rápido a la vez a comer y salir
inyectar a su hacia su búnker
bunker en la pieza de tu casa si vos
querés ver esa pieza decirle algo feo a
ver como te hace las puertas giratorias
le vas a poder ver te asomas la mira y
si no entras cuando él no está para
limpiarla
no identificado y si no identificado
para vos el loco ya no nos ha subido lo
ya no quiere vestirse como vos yo no soy
yo no soy yo ay qué linda más me
pregunta qué hago con esto qué hago con
esto como lo entiendo y vos porque de
ser un papá piola este me está diciendo
es que eres padre ni idea si ni ni idea
y si yo es un papá piola
y quiere decir sinvergüenza y tu hijo te
quiso matar está un amiguito encima te
odio te odio en ese momento pero también
vos en ese momento le brindas que la
oportunidad de que él te puede enseñar
algo
yo sí como si vos no sos ni tan ídolo ni
tan intocable ni tan lejano estamos a la
par
validamos las ideas de nuestros hijos
validamos que quizás su pensamiento es
tan bueno como el nuestro o mejor
acompañemos
la única forma que nuestros hijos tengan
presencia es mirándolos si no los
miramos no pueden ser
ellos tienen que ser los disruptivos
ellos tienen que estar enojados ellos
tienen que estar alejándose hablemos
charlemos ellos se alejan
o está cerca
ellos se alejan
o te acercas él se tiene que alejar vos
tenés que acompañar
que lo que podemos hacer
en cosas podemos hacer podemos hacer
cosas como papas podemos hacer cosas
como hijos podemos hacer cosas como en
la sociedad y la sociedad hay leyes
hagamos las cumplir las leyes que
tenemos si las aplicaremos nos ayudaría
en un montón
generemos elevemos propuestas para el
gobierno de turno para hacer talleres
extraescolares no competitivos barriales
inclusivos de arte de deporte brindemos
es ahora que tenemos para tener más
adolescentes estimulados este chico se
va a estimular de la misma manera que
con el alcohol pero es todo rédito
positivo va a estar con un adulto que lo
acompañe
las campañas las campañas funcionaron
funciona la campaña del cigarrillo ni
bien empezó la campaña del cigarrillo
todo se quejaba y se tenía y si van
dejándose hacia la puerta fumar afuera
cuando se quejan más pan y fuman afuera
la campaña del cinturón de seguridad
funcionó y si no funciona carne como
éste os amaro de plata y para no poner
que comerte la multa te pone el cinturón
generemos una campaña
como papá
a acompañar
estar charlar mirar escuchar vas a
escuchar que charlar aprendamos no algo
que nos guste le gusta este chico eso va
a generar un diálogo tu hijo no te
quiere mirar bueno habla caminando habla
en el auto vos está que el estar hace
que ese chico sepa que te tiene como
hijo y valora se aprendió youtube que a
vos te gustaba estuvo tres meses para
aprenderlo y algo encima te gusta otro
valorarlo o valorar que el tipo que
quería seguir durmiendo se levantó a las
tres la mañana para buscar una previa
luego quería dormir usted fue a buscar
la voz no es para él es para vos para
acompañarte para cuidarte y ajuste la
vergüenza pero mira los del otro lugar
cuando de tus amigos la están cuidando
como vos
valorarlo
a mí me interesaría
vamos hablar de números no tiene sentido
a mi mente sería que esta charla sesión
en dos cosas
y el alcohol
como están consumiendo estos chicos
adolescentes ahora es tóxico es nocivo
no dejan nada de rédito positivo
y lo más importante qué quiero que se
queden es que es posible disfrutar de tu
viejo
que es posible disfrutar de tu hijo
s mi viejo
yo y él nos pudimos disfrutar mi papá
fue perfecto no no hizo el curso mejor
padre no leyó el mejor libro con su
palabra ya les dije era un por dios
él estaba él siempre estaba yo le decía
gordo pelado botón con trenza
qué me pasa a mí porque yo no me mandaba
una macana
porque cuando yo me iba a estudiar veía
a mi familia a mi viejo y a mi hermano
corriendo al lado del colectivo para
saludarme un ratito más porque no sabía
cuándo podía volver
porque yo la mirada de mi viejo la tenía
acá a pesar de estar a 800 km yo no le
iba fas a mi familia porque mi familia
no me estaba fallando a mí
la de todo esto es que mi viejo
se fue antes de tiempo
porque su papá tomaba
no conoció a mi fan número 1 que es mi
marido no conoció a mis dos soles que
son mis hijos
yo quería que me entrar en la iglesia no
puedo hacer
teníamos mil proyectos juntos
no pasó entonces el alcohol destruye al
que toma y al que no toma salgan de acá
y abracen a sus familias salgan de aquí
la abracen a sus hijos salgan de acá y
abracen a sus padres muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]